all right let's get to uh audience
questions for the week
first one uh increasingly relevant as
the vaccine rollout continues
and vaccines are made avail available to
more and more americans
david do you know people personally who
are refusing to get the coronavirus
vaccine
you know i do and the i don't really
know
conspiracy theory types personally who
are saying oh it'll alter your dna
or you're going to get microchipped by
the vaccine i know that
a lot of people believe that because
i've seen the data seen the surveys
but i don't know any of those folks
personally what i'm seeing mostly in the
people i know
who are saying they're not planning to
get vaccinated or at least not for now
is lack of information they're just
ignorant to the fact so like as one
example
a friend of mine a couple of weeks ago
said um
i'm not going to uh i'm not even going
to think about getting a vaccine
until they do the phase 3 trials
and i explained to him for the approved
vaccines phase three trials have been
done i mean
the phase three trials have been done
for months and uh we got that data in
november december
and it was reviewed by the fda and then
an emergency use authorization
was put forward and he said really oh i
didn't know and i said yeah i mean that
you you need the phase three data there
was a discussion last summer
about do we not do we do an emergency
use order before finishing phase three
if the data looks good it wasn't done
phase three has been done and once i
explained that to him he said oh
well i guess i'll look into it now what
was really kind of scary is he works in
the health care field
and we've we've read about a number of a
significant portion of nurses and others
working in the healthcare field who are
saying i'm not going to get the vaccine
so that's
some some folks that i'm hearing from uh
who say they're not going to get it it's
something like that they don't think
it's been approved they don't think
phase 3 is done or whatever the case may
be
but phase 3 is done and there is an
emergency use authorization
the other people that i personally know
who are
you know refusing is a weird term now
because most of them aren't yet eligible
but who are telling me they don't a plan
to get a vaccine
um is that they're sort of saying it as
from a libertarian perspective like
they're against forced vaccination
and i kind of point out to them if
you're opting not to get it
clearly you're not forced and then this
gets into this weird discussion about
well if in order to fly
you are required to have it you are
being forced to get it and i i
try to explain there's a difference
between mandatory
and required for certain activities and
i end up kind of coming back to the same
place from this libertarian perspective
which is
as a libertarian do you respect the
right of
just hypothetically delta airlines to
say
we require people who want to fly with
us to present proof of vaccination
after a certain date and
they end up usually in a pretzel of some
kind where they are
uber libertarians who think businesses
shouldn't be regulated they should be
allowed to do whatever they want
and yet somehow they want to be able to
decide what delta's policy should be and
if they want to fly without a vaccine
they should be allowed to you've got to
you've got to be a little more
consistent here
and there is not going to be a mandatory
vaccination from the government
there's no legal basis to do that but
that being said
there are all sorts of different
institutions that might say if you want
to choose to avail yourself of our
product or service or to do business
with us
one of our requirements is that you be
vaccinated and
this is not legally uh problematic this
is not constitutionally an issue
etc now in terms of the number of people
remaining in the u.s who don't plan to
get the vaccine
i don't know whether to say we're in a
good place or we're not in a good place
there was a point
months and months ago where more than
half the country
said they did not plan to get a
coronavirus vaccine that number is down
to about a third of the country and it
continues to go down
it's good that the percentage of people
who don't plan to get it has basically
dropped by half
the concerning part is that
i don't know that with two-thirds of
adult getting the vaccine two-thirds of
adults getting it and one-third not that
we're going to reach herd immunity and
that's really the concern at this point
dr fauci and others have said
in particular since we're not going to
be vaccinating kids in
in the immediate we need close to
all adults to get the vaccine
particularly with these more
transmissible variants to really have
herd immunity and protection so the
there's good news here which is vaccine
hesitancy is declining
the bad news is there's still a lot of
people including
otherwise educated individuals
who think everything from the vaccine
will alter your dna
to it'll allow the government to track
you oh oh oh
which reminds me there is one
acquaintance this is not a friend but
it's an acquaintance
who posted to facebook not long ago
uh i have some reasonable concerns about
the vaccine i'm not saying i'm not going
to get it but i
i do believe this that and that
it could be used to track my location
and
a lot of our shared friends started
trying to talk her off the ledge
i just had to unfriend it's just i can't
do it guys
i can't do it and i know many of you
have come up against the same situation